i knew he wanted me out he wanted me out
from before i even got there like from
the moment the news came out that i was
signing he was trying to get me to not
even have day one at espn and so
just being 100 honest i'm a petty guy
there was a part of me that almost
wanted to stay
in spite of him
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
we're live now so we we always hit
recording right now oh wow geez
so hitting me with the uh the blindsided
live i like it
well it said that's how the real pros do
it i don't know how you guys do it on tv
but the real pros just go live abruptly
in midtown i love it i love it i'm
always ready so we um
do
we got introduced to a friend my uh our
buddy john who's apparently your closest
buddy and um i like i don't know what
you know about us and we could tell you
about it in a minute but basically like
we're pretty popular in the business
world and let's start with that yeah
pretty big deal
anthony pettis is a fan i know that yes
we're not nearly as big of a deal as you
are in your world but like you know
we're on the cusp of being pretty big
and
uh we've talked to a bunch of amazing
people we've talked to titans of
industry we've talked to billionaires
we've talked to people who have tens of
thousands employees people who products
you use whatever i have never been as
starstruck or as nervous to talk to
someone else
no i swear to god ariel i've been
listening to you for for maybe 10 years
uh i've never been this nervous okay um
and so for the audience at home uh the
only reason why sam is saying this right
now is because i think you recorded this
after the uh the explanation of what
happened last time we were supposed to
actually do this a month ago and he
stood me up so he's trying to butter me
up because he still feels bad he was in
some villa in hawaii i'm on the east
coast freezing my butt off here
and he didn't wake up in time and now
he's trying to tell me that he
uh is star struck in front of me get out
of here with this no i i i i i kept as
the kids say this is full cap right here
all right there's no
sam doesn't know he doesn't know cap he
doesn't know this sort of modern lingo
well i i've been
i've been dead honest uh like we've
talked to a lot of wonderful amazing
people i've never been this nervous
because you
you're you don't take a lot of
you uh you you call people out you know
the whole thing with brendan schaub is
amazing um the whole giovanni the whole
thug knows i know about it all ceo pf
that's amazing that is incredible like
every one of your guests takes their
interviews from the phone while driving
i'm shocked you're not doing that i know
no
every time like they go to me uh you
know like it's all right now let's join
uh so and so thank you for joining us
blah blah and and then they go to the
shot and they're in the car i'm like ah
for sake you're in the car really
why did you tell me that this was a good
time if you're in the car i don't know
there's just something
less intimate about the car maybe for
other people it's more intimate but i
don't know when you're at home you're
comfortable you've got your little water
bottle or coffee next to you it just
seems like you're going to get better
stuff but um
all that aside thank you for having me
in fact a very good friend of mine not
named john beer named kevin wang of
montreal give him a shout out he
currently lives in new york as well i've
known him for quite some time when i
think you sent out the initial tweet
that i would be on
he within seconds sent me the screen
grab and said this is my favorite
podcast i can't believe you're gonna be
on it uh this is incredible tell me more
all this stuff and more so a lot of
people are apparently excited i
appreciate you guys having me no hard
feelings it took me a couple days to get
over being stood up uh you know i had to
rearrange my whole schedule and
cancel on some people and things like
that but with uh with great pleasure i
return to do this for real
good and and uh we're gonna do an intro
ahead of this so we don't need to tell
talk too much about your credentials but
basically for the people who aren't
listening ariel you've been you've been
in this people who for the people who
aren't listening i don't know i don't
think they care sorry
see i told you i'm nervous
for the people who who don't follow you
you're basically you've been in the game
since 06 you worked for
vox you worked for espn you worked for a
ton of different uh amazing publications
but you you started as a reporter at
this point i would say you're just as
much of a character of the mma scene ufc
scene as dana as some of the fighters
don't tell dana that
well i i you're definitely you're you
know you're as much of the story
sometimes as a lot of the stuff going on
which is awesome and you've built this
amazingly large and loyal audience uh
we're a business podcast so we could
talk a little bit about mma but what's
interesting is that you've recently kind
of gone uh semi-independent so you work
with bt sports you work with spotify you
work with sub stack although you don't
work with them but you know what i mean
you have a sub stack and what you're
doing with journalism and
an entrepreneur in terms of entrepreneur
being an entrepreneur is pretty amazing
um so you kind of like have this
independent uh business where i think
it's kind of interesting and i think if
you are a young person wanting to get
into business journalism business media
what you are doing and also what some of
the other guys are doing bisping chael
sonnen i think that is the the
perfect example of what you can become
so that's why we asked you to come on
well i appreciate that and i could tell
you how i uh arrived to this point in my
life if you'd like
um
i kind of feel like i'm an entrepreneur
at heart but i say that with the caveat
that i'm a horrible business person when
i think of things like finances stocks
uh investments like it truly makes my
head hurt my older brother mark is uh
someone who's very good at this stuff my
dad is very good at this stuff my
brother works in uh the financial
industry and all this i was always more
of the sports fan the creative the
dreamer that type of person
however i consider myself an
entrepreneur in the sense that i have
always tried to do things
solo
on my own bet on myself when i went to
syracuse university as a youngster i was
the only one of my friends who left
montreal to go um study in the united
states in canada where i'm from in
montreal no one leaves they all just go
to either mcgill or concordia and so i
felt like i was kind of you know
building my own thing then when i got
there i uh i create you know i i went to
the the traditional so syracuse
university in case you don't know is the
number one school
for at least in my opinion to develop
sports broadcasters and they've
developed the likes of you know the
likes of bob costas went there and marv
albert and mike tarico i mean the list
is just incredible the names of the
people who uh you know went to study at
syracuse over the years and they all go
to this one station waer to hone their
craft and develop a voice and all that
stuff and i went there and i noticed uh
that everyone kind of wanted to be the
same person and i never wanted to follow
anyone and so i left that station after
one semester and i went to like the
rinky dink third tier student station um
in the student center and i did my own
combat sports show every saturday
morning over there and so again i was
kind of just doing things on my own and
trying to build out my own thing fast
forward a long time i get to spike tv in
i hate it after a week i start my own
website and that's how i get into mma
journalism um and i start interviewing
fighters and i give myself six months to
get noticed i don't get paid for any of
this i was just kind of using this as an
opportunity to show people what i can do
fast forward to now and in february i'm
starting to
realize that my time at espn is probably
coming to an end and i'm starting to
think to myself okay what do i want to
do what would make me happy what's the
future here and what i came uh to
realize was i can almost create this
menu this puzzle as i called it where
i'm doing this here this here this here
that here
and i call myself independent helwani
independent helwani and yes i'm working
with other people but i feel very
independent because i was able to go out
and carve up my duties um some of it's
my own my own youtube channel the
substance things like that and some of
it is i consider partnering with other
people and uh it's uh it's been an
incredible few months since i was able
to leave i was terrified of leaving it
initially because espn was my dream i
actually had to talk to a therapist
about that and we can get into that as
well because i didn't feel i felt like a
failure if i left after three years
because this was my dream this was the
mountaintop but i was very unhappy and i
realized that i had to go back to that
entrepreneurial spirit and start
building out my own things and start
doing what made me happy and be around
people who make me happy and people who
support you don't want to stab you in
the back and all this stuff and so yeah
i'm very very happy now now i'm working
with vox my old friends at vox media
with the ringer spotify with sub stack
with bt sport i did a thing for showtime
recently bet mgm and uh it's great i've
never been busier but i've never been
happier as well and talk about that that
move so you're at espn
the dream is realized because you're
kind of like
you're like me i don't know if you
remember there was a show back in the
day about becoming a sports center
anchor do you ever watch this show oh
yeah it was like it was like a reality
show and it was only on for like two
seasons or something like that but it
was great i think anybody who grew up
kind of with sportscenter on loop uh you
know there was something really
aspirational about espn you get there
and was it that
and so this can happen that happens with
all kinds of entrepreneurs you'll sell
your company and then you'll feel like
kind of numb slash board like wait was
this it this is the thing i was working
for this whole time um so was it that
the dream really wasn't a dream or was
it that oh it came to an end and i got
to figure out where to from here so what
was the espn
side like did the mountaintop feel like
you thought it would feel or what was
that like
yeah so that's a great question i always
wanted to work at espn that was sort of
the end goal i remember being a young
kid going on vacation to the united
states with my family
we'd get to the hotel and my brothers
and i would watch sportscenter on loop
remember in the mornings they would have
like one
episode that they would tape and they
would just repeat it over and over again
and i would repeat it and i was just so
taken by the magic of sports television
and the characters and the highlights
and all this stuff
and i'll be honest when i got there
right off the bat uh i was disappointed
the first few months at espn were very
hard for me uh because i had this vision
in my mind of what it would be like
and the resources
and the commitment to you know excellent
content and coverage and
attention to detail and all this stuff
and it honestly it just wasn't what i
expected now over time we kind of found
our groove and i got to do a lot of fun
things and i'll be honest in the back of
my mind i was like i don't know how long
i'm going to last here
partly because of the fit but also
partly because of the relationship with
the ufc and not being able to cover the
sport the way i want to cover the sport
and i tried to check off as many boxes
as possible and so hosting a radio show
i wanted to do that i checked that off
doing an e60 profile on my good friend
daniel cormier i checked that off doing
nba sidelines i checked that off
otl outside the lines checked it out
sportscenter checked it out so i was
trying to do as much as possible because
i knew at some point this was not i was
not going to be a 25-year lifer i came
to that conclusion pretty early on one
of those guys who stays at espn for all
those years and uh you know it was tough
you know i'm going from doing a show in
a beautiful studio that i helped um
design in in a in in new york city to a
very small studio uh with not the same
resources to then going to bristol
connecticut twice a week driving four
hours back and forth mondays and
wednesdays
to bristol's it's a four-hour back and
forth so two hours and two hours in the
same day twice a week
and uh you know sometimes it's you know
it's your exhaust i'm doing a show
that's three four hours long i'm
mentally tired after this show and i
have to get back in my car and drive two
hours
often in the winter it's pitch black
like this wasn't very fun um and yet
here i am you know it's the dream job
it's espn and then on top of that it's
all the other drama that you have to
deal with behind the scenes so yeah i
mean i came to the conclusion around a
year ago well not a year ago now like
last summer
okay you know what do you want to do
what would make you happy um
would leaving be
the right move would that make you happy
and you know i there was a part of you
know i knew
honestly i knew there were people that
probably wanted me to leave
you know what i'm talking about people
in the ufc probably wanted me to leave
um
if you're not listening basically you've
had and you just actually did a
wonderful youtube yesterday where you
explained the background but basically
you've had an issue or dana white the
the president of ufc has had an issue
with you for a variety of reasons
whether he claims you're too negative he
says you've you've uh
leaked some information there's always
been some tension there all of it's
wrong uh he couldn't be more wrong but
you know he has his uh
he has his business and his motives and
uh and and it would be it would be great
if we could meet in the middle like we
once did but you know uh that's neither
here nor there at this point um so yes i
knew he wanted me out he wanted me out
from before i even got there like from
the moment the news came out that i was
signing he was trying to get me to not
even have day one at espn and so
just being 100 honest i'm a petty guy
there was a part of me that almost
wanted to stay
in spite of him and i didn't want them
to win i didn't want them to win because
i knew that they would celebrate if i
left in fact when i announced that i was
leaving espn i got a text message from
an unknown number that's not on my phone
saying i told you we'd get you out of
espn bye-bye now i don't know who sent
me that text message i have my theories
but like i so i needed to go talk to
someone to figure out how to get over
that to not stay at a job
in spite of someone which is absolutely
ludicrous to do what makes me happy to
to have fulfillment in my heart um you
know to wake up and be excited to be
around people that make you you know
happy and support you and all that stuff
i had to get over that in my brain and
thankfully i did um and so it took it
took some time i don't have any regrets
do you tell the therapist about petty
helwani about helwani do they does the
therapist support all these characters
that you have in your arsenal
sometimes she's like okay what is the
end goal here what are you trying to
accomplish are you bringing more stress
um but she really helped me
realize what is important and what makes
me happy and not sticking around to you
know stick it to people and things like
that and as i said on my show on
wednesday i don't know if i end up at
this point if uh if i don't talk to a
therapist and i was always someone who
was afraid of talking to a therapist
because i thought that it made me weak i
thought that it it it would be um a sign
of weakness that i was you know um you
know needing help and all this stuff and
and honestly uh i'm so happy and
thankful that i got to that point it was
a weird way to get there but you know
i'm happy that i was able to talk to
someone who helped me figure things out
therapy is like exercise i'm like look
even if you look skinny you should still
exercise you know even if you're like in
an okay place you should still go and do
stuff and particularly if you're fat you
should exercise if you're in a bad
mental spot you should definitely go and
do therapy so i don't think you exercise
my peloton bike helped me a lot i got
one of those i mean a lot of things
helped me clear my head and
i don't have any regrets i don't even
have uh one thing that i had to talk out
was i didn't want to have
ill feelings towards espn i love sports
i was just watching my knicks beat the
celtics in an incredible double overtime
thriller last night on espn i didn't
want to be the guy who couldn't watch
espn who couldn't go on the app who felt
some sort of way about this company that
meant so much to me
and live with that animosity and i was
afraid that that would happen
i don't have any of it i don't have any
animosity towards them the people there
i don't have any animosity towards
anyone there to be honest because they
they kept their word they paid me till
the very end they stayed true to the
contract they even offered me a new
contract unlike what other people are
trying to say about me being fired i was
never fired they offered me a contract
and i turned it down
and i met some legend mike breen doris
burke i met absolute legends of the tv
business there i will never forget my
time and i'm very thankful for the time
but three years was enough it was time
to move on
can i ask you i want to ask you two
questions the the second one is actually
going to be about dana white and um i
want to ask you about what attributes do
you think he he has that have made ufc
wonderful and and and that's what i've
asked people about you i asked john go
man ariel's amazing what drives them so
it's always fun to ask other people
about like the the the people they work
with but the first question is the the
current setup right now with your
business what do you think is going to
be the biggest revenue driver is
substack do you think gonna drive you
know this paid newsletter business is
that going to drive a significant amount
do you think it's most going to come
from bt sport from youtube ads what
how's your your business set up and
where's your head at in terms of where
the opportunity is
right now uh my my biggest
revenue driver if if you want to put in
those terms is uh is vox media they're
they're paying me the most um and that
was important to me because the mma hour
was a show that i created and put a lot
of time and effort and uh you know just
i mean everything i poured everything
into that show
from 2009 all the way to 2018 and it was
heartbreaking to see it end even though
i was going to my dream job um that show
just meant so much to me and i think it
meant a lot to a lot of people and so
that's the biggest one and that's a do
you regard that as a youtube channel or
or
youtube and the and the the podcast does
very well it's on apple it's on spotify
it's on google it's on stitcher all
those places as well and you own it i do
not own it no i don't own it they pay me
to do that show uh so that's what's
interesting about my situation is like
some of the stuff i own some of the
stuff i don't own but everyone's playing
nicely together in this sandbox and i'm
very appreciative it took some time to
kind of
figure out all the pieces that was the
most interesting part of this like
back in in february so when i came to
the conclusion that i was gonna go and
uh leave espn and try to do things here
and there
obviously you have oh i'd like to do
this and that like some people call it a
chinese menu you know you kind of build
your out your own thing but then the
actual
dance of getting everyone to play nice
and be on board with all these little
different things that i'm doing was the
most interesting part of the whole
process and i really lucked out and i
found all these people like people who
are okay with me having my own youtube
channel that's completely mine and the
sub stack but also doing something for
the ringer spotify and also doing
something for vox and b so um it's just
it's just been a really interesting um
exercise in look i i like my friend uh
pat mcafee here i am dropping uh names
um he's like oh well you're not totally
independent you don't own everything i'm
like okay fine if you want to get you
know uh into that whole semantics game
fine i don't own everything but there's
an independent spirit to all of this
where at the end of the day i feel like
i'm partnering with other people as
opposed to being a full-time employee
with anyone i'm not i have an llc now
and uh i'm able to pick and choose what
i want to do um and so that's that's
really important but to answer your
question
the biggest deal that i have at the
moment is
my deal with vox media
do you think long term that stays true
or do you think because some things are
are some things pay off better
immediately and then some things you say
okay
if i build i don't know the newsletter
if i build the the podcast or the ring
or stuff if i build that up three years
from now this picture might look a
little different or do you you said you
don't really think too much about
business do you not even care about that
you just do your thing and see what
happens are you trying to get me to
reveal my five year plan my business
plan right here
that's exactly what i'm trying to do i'm
looking for 20 30 ariel where's 20 30
ariel doing like
what what who's the guy who started the
ringer what's his name again bill
simmons yeah like you know he was in a
similar position as you sold the ringer
probably netted 150 200 million dollars
when he did that i mean is that going to
happen to to you
that would be nice um i don't know you
know
right now
um
obviously i'm i'm very happy with the
situation i'm really excited and it's
kind of the thing that's flying under
the radar at the moment which i'm
totally okay with that uh what i'm doing
on my own youtube channel is giving me
as i like to say a lot of nachas nachas
is a yiddish word which means kind of
like fulfillment and joy in my heart
because uh every week for now every
thursday i am posting an interview with
someone outside of the mma world because
i've been itching for a very long time
and that was part of the reason why i
went to espn
to show people that i'm more than just
an mma guy that i can interview
other athletes authors musicians
comedians anyone it doesn't matter if
you're in the sports world if you're an
actor if you're a holocaust survivor if
you're interesting i want to talk to you
because the thing that i derive the most
enjoyment from
are the interviews i love talking to
people i could do a hunt i mean i do a
four-hour show twice a week now and uh i
feel like i can do it every day it's
just a lot of uh fun for me and so i've
i started that around a month and a half
or so ago and uh it's just my own little
thing it's it's me and two producers an
audio guy video guy and we're posting
these interviews and i don't honestly
care
at this moment if a million people watch
these interviews or
three people watch the interviews for
for me now i'm doing them
to uh you know fulfill you know this
this little you know
passion of mine to talk to other people
to scratch that itch but also to
eventually show people the right kind of
people um that i could do this that i
could be much more than just
an mma guy and it's actually the exact
same thought process that i had when i
got into all of this
back in 2007 in fact uh this past
tuesday october 19th
marked the 14-year
anniversary of me launching my own site
jerrypark.com it's still up um i was at
spike tv
in september of 2007 i got a job working
at spike tv and spike tv was the home of
the ufc and i was working in tv
production i thought okay this is the
best place for me tv production ufc
uh they're the home of the ufc it's
perfect after a week there i walked into
my boss's office
and uh i quit and i said uh i i don't
really think this is the right fit for
me i'm not i really like they didn't do
anything creative i'm a creative guy i
like to think of ideas come up with
things and they were just kind of the
middle man the ufc was producing all the
content so i walked into his office i
said i'm really sorry thank you for the
opportunity but i don't think this is
the right fit and i'm the kind of guy
who um when he's 85 years old i i don't
want to wake up and say i could have
done this i should have done this i
should have zigged when i zagged all
that stuff he was very upset he said
you're going to regret this for the rest
of your life this is unprofessional no
one's ever done this blah blah blah and
they made me stick around for a month
and a half in my cubicle until they
found someone to replace me and that was
the crossroads of my life
in fact our mutual friend john was a
part of this process where you know i
would we would go for lunch during this
process i'm not doing anything and i'm
telling him i'm going to start my own
website and i'm going to start
interviewing fighters because i really
want to go into mma journalism i really
want to show people that i could be the
howard cosell the the max kellerman the
whatever of mma and so i started to
reach out to fighters via myspace and
every morning i would post an interview
with a fighter and i didn't care if five
people looked at the interviews or 500
000. i just wanted to use that to show
people that i could do that
14 years later i'm doing the same thing
on my youtube page and now i want to
build this and grow it um and and use it
as an opportunity to show people but for
now it's just like giving me so much joy
to go back to those early days and just
talk to people about things and then now
i'm like last week i interviewed marty
fish the former tennis player who's been
you know very open with his battles with
anxiety and friends of mine who have
never listened to my work watched my
work ever who don't care about mma are
like wow dude you're a really good
interviewer i'm like yeah i've been
doing this for 14 years at this point
but it's it's opening me up to a whole
new audience and i'm very excited about
that
we have uh a couple of kind of like just
go-to phrases or principles when it
comes to business one of them is bet on
yourself
and uh and i think you so so some people
are like you know if some people are
listening to this they're not super into
mma i think one of the things they could
pull out is
your bet on yourself mentality
especially when it's not easy right like
uh betting on yourself sometimes as an
entrepreneur it's kind of obvious you
don't really have a job you you know by
default you better on yourself you had
quote unquote good jobs at each of these
stops and then you said look this isn't
it i'm going to bet on myself and i'm
going to go independent i'm going to do
my thing so you have a strong dose of
bed on yourself even another one that
sam sam uh coined which is niches get
riches which is that i know you're a
basketball fan but you didn't go into
the more established field that one that
had a career track that you could tell
your mom look there's other people who
have made it in this field i could be
the next whatever uh in basketball you
went for mma which is today fringe let
alone back in you know 2006 or whatever
like nobody was really
there was no blueprint or there was no
like um success stories doing what you
were doing i don't think at that time
like you are the kind of the success
story of that niche and so i want to
hear kind of how you decided to bet on
that even though you have other
interests you have other sports that
you're interested in as well um and then
the last one is
there's this great phrase which is uh
you know you want to do the work that
feels like that looks like work to
others but it feels like play to you so
like if i was going to interview
somebody four hours a day
i would be exhausted and i think you get
your pick up steam by energy by your
hour three you're like you're just
hitting your groove and it gives you
energy so i think that's another example
of where you you kind of live one of
these principles that we talk about but
tell me about the niche thing
oh why did you see that that spoke to my
heart that spoke to my heart that's a
great line uh niches get riches because
i couldn't agree with you more um when i
got to syracuse for the first time my
life like when i went to syracuse i
wanted to be the next costas marv albert
basketball baseball football traditional
guy hello welcome to abc sports i'm
maria helwani world series super bowl
and for the first time my life i
realized wow there's a lot of people in
this world who are my age who have the
exact same dream as me who are a little
more polished who have nicer hair who
don't have as big of a nose and maybe
don't have such a foreign name their
name is john smith and they just kind of
fit that bob costas mold
and i never i never liked to follow you
know the pack and so i remember telling
my parents in september of 2001 there's
this sport called mixed martial arts
there's this organization called the ufc
at this point it's not even eight years
old and i think it's going to be
mainstream and i think in 10 years
there's going to be some executive in
some office some older guy who's like
what is this crazy cage fighting sport i
know nothing about it but apparently
it's very popular who's the guy who's
the voice who's the howard cosell of mma
and i want to be that guy
and amazingly
literally 10 years later august of 2011
i was hired by fox and that was like my
first big you know mainstream gig um and
so it kind of worked out in that regard
but i i say this to young people all the
time when they reach out to me and they
send me you know oh i want to do this i
want to do that i want to be you know
stephen a smith and all this stuff
in this day and age
you don't want to be a generalist you
you you you're a fan of the new york
knicks you're a fan of the new york
knickerbockers i'm not gonna go tune in
to the radio espn radio now i'm not
gonna go in my car tune in and say oh i
hope you guys talk about the nick
celtics game last night i'm gonna go on
my podcast app and i'm going to go to
the new york knicks podcast as niche as
it gets to hear an hour breakdown of
last night's game if i'm a big pro
wrestling fan i'm going to go to my pro
wrestling podcast and listen to mma
podcasts listen business podcast the
days of sitting in your car and hoping
that they talk about something or
listening to people just talk about god
knows what those days are over and so it
is actually a lot better in my opinion
to go into a niche to be the niche guy
as opposed to being the generals yeah
there's a couple guys who will make it
steven and those guys but for the most
part in my world it's way better to be
the niche guy and i try to explain that
and and within the niche
have your own niche as well and so like
my thing interviews i tell other people
like find your thing there was a young i
always bring up mike bond he works for
mma junkie and he's a lot younger than i
am his niche that he used to get in the
door were stats and factoids so he would
have all these stats about all the
fighters great these days maybe it's
bedding betting is super hot right now
use that as your niche to get in the
door so yes i i couldn't agree more with
that mindset um and and i would urge
anyone in this day and a this day and
age of a la carte you know
everything is out of the car right
podcast streaming all that the more
niche the better you'll have way more
success rather than being just some guy
like those days 50 years ago when you
were a columnist for a newspaper those
days are over
how um how what
what what size or how big is your your
audience i mean i know the youtube
videos get like thirty thousand a
hundred thousand per per clip per video
how
what do you say the number is of your
audience and what advice do you have you
could use us for example i mean we're
smaller than you um of like of of your
tips for getting noticed and being great
at building this this empire this is
gonna sound uh
don't tell me good content no no no no
it's gonna sound wack but i really don't
know the size i mean i see the numbers
on youtube i never asked for the podcast
numbers i don't want to know and it's
actually one thing that really bothered
me at espn like
three weeks into my time there we sat
down and started like breaking down the
numbers and the listening
rate and and the completion rate and all
this stuff like i don't want to know
this like it's hard enough i by the way
in in the uh what is it now 12 years of
me doing this like hosting this type of
weekly show and all this stuff shows
i've never had a person book the guest
for me i i book every single guest every
single name that you see on my show on
on wednesday rose and jan behoevic and
fedor i book those people myself i do
not have a booker what do you just dm
them on twitter i mean how do you dm
fedor
now i have you know i have their numbers
uh you know it and i know what everyone
likes like i know there's some people
who respond quicker to dms there are
some people who respond quicker to
whatsapp there are some people who run
quicker to imessage uh i never email
anyone uh i mean you email a fighter
that's like throwing you know a
toothpick into the ocean
there's no chance you're getting a
message back but uh you know i'm just
i'm kind of relentless like that and i'm
obsessive like that and i think that i
would drive someone crazy if i said hey
i want to get uh rose number eunice on
my show and then i would probably ask
them a million times did she respond did
she respond did she respond so i'd
rather just put that on myself now it's
probably the worst part of the job and
it makes me uh you know very stressed
out but it's just the way i like to do
things so that brings enough stress now
to know you know completion rate and
downloads and subs yeah but you must
have an idea you have a million
followers on twitter i think bt sport
has 1.2 million subscribers on youtube
ish um your videos ballpark 50 000 to
100 000 views per maybe i don't know
what your podcast downloads are but like
do you know
no one no one has talked to me now okay
i'll tell you like at espn uh when my
show with dc towards the end we were
getting i think on the podcast only now
this is one little sticking point that i
have
so they would sit down and they'd be
like okay the podcast with dc is getting
around 90 000 downloads uh an episode
like all right that's pretty good 90 000
an episode once a week one hour a week
but here's the problem they were
comparing us to other podcast only shows
let's say the low post podcast the
basketball podcast hosted by the great
zak low but that's an audio only podcast
we have the youtube show as well so our
audience is splintered so if you want to
know about you know our total audience
you got to count those numbers as well
and in addition you want to get into
dude i've never listened i listen to you
every single time i've never listened to
you on the podcast app
so that's yeah so that's the thing like
uh and it would always annoy me that we
were just focused what about the youtube
numbers like to me i'm more of a visual
guy and i care more about that like the
the the audio podcast is almost like
gravy for me if you're in your car or
whatever but i'm i'm more inclined to
push the video so
um i would guess
if we're gonna use those numbers that's
from a few uh months ago and i don't
feel like we've really missed a beat on
mma fighting since i returned there from
the video you know we're talking like
200 250 but then then there's the
breakout stuff right like because then
each each interview gets
made into its own separate clip so i
don't know man what you're trying to
stress me out here i'm just trying to
live my life and no you're getting
confused you gave an answer so you think
uh 200 200k ish
i'll tell you why i think something like
that matters what are we at 50 or i
think we're at 60 000 an episode if you
add the youtube and the pod so i think
that's amazing like like i think i've
been studying a bunch of different
people from uh you know like there's
there's there's you in let's say mma and
then there's uh you know i don't know if
you follow cryptocurrency with this guy
pomp and he's like the bitcoin guy and
then there's tim ferriss and he's like
you know the four-hour workweek guy
there's all these people who build their
brands they're what i call you know
solopreneurs or solo media people and
and you could look at it i did a
comparison once of of rogan's show
versus you know the the the like the
tonight show
and on every metric it's like you know
not even close
you know how many viewers do you get how
much money do you bring in how many
employees do you have and on every
metric rogan just like like beats down
the tonight show and uh but people would
still sort of from a prestige point of
view they think one is a television show
where you wear a fancy suit and you have
a monologue and a fake audience clapping
and the other one is like you know you
just got done with a workout you sit
down in this little studio and you do a
podcast what the heck's a podcast so
people haven't really caught up on this
model um and then i sort of broke down
the businesses of each i said oh okay
interesting so what it looks like to me
is you get this number that i call your
true fans which is basically like the
number of people who really trust you
and like let's say that's like a quarter
million people for you or something like
that maybe it's 250 000 people that
really trust you i'll follow you i don't
really care if you're on espn or mma
fighting or you're with bt sport i just
know ariel helwani and i'll just kind of
follow you wherever you go it's like a
fan of lebron james they're not a
cleveland cavs fan they're a lebron fan
and now they're all lakers fans and so
then i sort of studied the model and i
said okay it looks like between two to
four percent of your audience will sort
of buy anything you do like they'll pay
for your paid newsletter they'll buy
your your your hoodies um you know you
tell them hey i'm ariel i've raised a
venture capital fund i'm investing in
startups now they'll invest in your fund
they'll do everything and so now there's
all these new models before it used to
be you know you get famous and you write
a book you spend a couple years you
write a book and that's how you that's
how you monetize your audience and then
people started doing courses and other
other different things like that
and i've been studying all the different
models one of the guys i got friendly
with was matthew berry at espn because
he has a niche which is fantasy football
and he was doing this you know before
fantasy was sexy he was like convincing
yahoo and others hey go into fantasy i'm
telling you like guys are nuts about
this and he became the fantasy guy and
he's kind of like you he's got a little
bit of he's got a cushy gig with espn
but he's got a bit of independence he's
got his own like text message like list
and he's got his own fantasy football
thing oh does he do that i didn't know
he i didn't know he uh he had he's got a
couple carve outs
i actually asked espn in our
negotiations i was like well what if i
do this like if i just do the dc show
and the chill show but then i do this
other stuff my own and uh i don't know
it just uh because it's not easy
i think he has a couple of carve outs
there for him work for him for him and
he got it kind of grandfathered in
basically he's like yeah i get to keep
deciding i don't make too big a fuss but
if you go look at his twitter bio what
does he link to it's like i think he
links to one of his properties basically
as like one of his things so i've been
studying this model i would say for you
i i i think you're in a great spot and
you know if you just sort of think about
like
the menu of ways that how does somebody
who's got a trusted loyal audience
they've built over 10 years monetized
there's all these creative ways beyond
um
beyond you know ads or sponsors on my on
my show i don't know if you care about
that stuff but i know i do care about it
you know it's interesting like the sub
stack thing is super interesting because
i would say of the
you know the three main things that i do
like obviously there's uh video audio
and writing um and there's there's
different components all of those but
like those are obviously you know audio
visual and writing i feel very confident
in my abilities as a video host and as
an audio host i don't feel as confident
in my abilities as a writer now
people tell me i'm good i just don't
feel like i'm as good and i try to be
very genuine when i write i try to be
myself not someone else um and i talk to
a bunch of people about the writing
component of my menu
and everyone wanted me to do stuff that
i wasn't really down with the guys at
sub stack so i i'm part of this like sub
stack pro model i don't know if you guys
know about this okay yeah and we've
talked to those guys uh hamish and all
those guys a fair bit we like him yeah
yeah so uh there was a guy named dan
stone who's a great guy he reached out
to me and they basically like
pitched me this thing where i could kind
of do whatever i want and there's
obviously this small component of it
that's uh behind a paywall i did not
feel comfortable with the paywall i'm
just being honest i said the same to him
i did not i did not i think most people
are in the same boat as you who come
from your background i do i don't want
to look i i've always been free and uh
that that's a weird thing in its own
right because like 30 40 years ago
you know you're subscribing to sports
illustrated you're subscribed like none
we've we've all we've programmed the
audience to expect everything to be free
when in reality like this stuff does
you know this stuff is worth something
and and it technically shouldn't be free
but it's been that way and it's hard to
go back it's hard to put the toothpaste
back in the the tube and so i didn't
feel comfortable doing that and so the
conclusion but i really wanted to work
with substance and so the conclusion
that i came to was uh all the proceeds
that i was getting from the subs i'm
donating to charity so i want people to
know i'm not profiting off of any of
this
why i mean i don't feel comfortable i
don't feel comfortable dude that's crazy
so uh my company uh i just so this this
podcast was owned by my company called
the hustle we we just sold it for a lot
of money too this company called hubspot
and before we sold it thank you and
before we sold it we had a daily email
that reached around 2 million people a
day and then we owned a subscription
business called trends that made many
millions of dollars and we charged 300 a
year i think we undercharged
what is going on like most creators feel
exactly how you feel and i'm like you're
crazy if you owned a restaurant
and you were cooking every single day
grinding eight hours a day would you
give that food away for free i can't do
it i don't know why i could even even
stemming from like the shop stuff
uh this this company breaking tea who i
think are fascinating you guys should
have those guys on they basically like
react to actually they made this
sweatshirt i don't even know what what's
their name so breaking tea like breaking
news so they're like kind of quick on
trends with this exactly so like let's
say uh
for example off top my head jorge
mousevides or nick diaz says don't be
scared homie the next day they have a
t-shirt out a really cool one and
they're selling it but they have deals
with mlbpa nhlpa so they're making stuff
in real time it's a fascinating business
and so one of the guys there
was a fan and made a helwani shirt in
the midst of like my whole thing i was
like oh this is great and we split the
cost and all of that i'm donating to
charity as well i don't want it i don't
know you've got this like this is
actually like you know philanthropy
that's crazy i i i i love you ariel and
i think you're totally wrong i've
listened to you enough that i know that
you uh you know i'm married into a
jewish family you've got this very like
stereotypical jewish guilt about you of
like your life
and um i i think that's weird i i i i
think you i think you are totally uh
downplay you know it's funny i watch you
in the interviews and i can tell you're
nervous or you are having issues like
realizing that you're the and so
as a fan i will say i think you're
undervaluing yourself um
what uh can i give you can i give you a
free idea here for for as a creator uh
no charge for you ariel you're a friend
of the house so here's a free idea for
you okay one of the new little tools in
the creator playbook of how to make a
bunch of money i don't know if you saw
this but mr beast who's one of the
biggest youtubers out there
launched this pop-up restaurant uh and
and celebrities doing restaurants kind
of been a thing but like back in the day
it was sort of like you know it was like
margaritaville or like gordon ramsay's
wolfgang puck kitchen or whatever the
hell these things are um
but mr beast came out with mr beast
burger and overnight he had 200
locations across the country and um and
you know you think about that has this
guy been pouring his you know that did
that take years of preparation no what
what's happened is there's these
companies like breaking tea that exists
that will create a virtual restaurant
brand and what they do is they partner
with like let's say you did yes i don't
know i don't know what you're uh maybe
it's chinese food i don't know what your
thing would be let's just say for a
second it's it's pizza balls
okay
you went niche again like i don't know
how big the market is there but let's
say
let's say it was pizza just for for
ease here
um there's a whole bunch of mom and pop
pizza shops in every city what this
company does they go partner with one in
phoenix and san francisco and all these
different cities and they say hey we're
gonna send you some packaging that's
custom helwani branded packaging and
only on you know saturday nights when
there's a ufc pay-per-view does this
restaurant go live and the menu is
themed for like it'll be like you know
you know a mazda pepperoni and like you
know a diaz burger and whatever else and
you or you know you make up your own
names and then basically your fans can
kind of order with the pay-per-view now
mr beast he did his little pop-up thing
so he didn't have to really lift a
finger he just kind of said all right
when i'll give you some ideas on the
branding of what the menu could look
like you know and i approve it yeah i'll
approve it i'll put it i'll put my name
behind it and then when the time comes
i'm going to tweet out that hey this is
happening and today you can go buy from
my thing
and i think this thing is done about
over somewhere between 50 and 100
million dollars in revenue off this
thing i think you know if you just sort
of assume a 10 you know kickback royalty
that he's getting on this
i i'm pretty confident he's doing
somewhere between three and six million
a year of just
recurring passive revenue
um from the
uh from his little mr beast burger thing
now you're not mr beast but you could do
something alongside the the
pay-per-views and that would just be for
fun
your fans i'm going to steal that i'm
going to steal that but you should i
can't really shoot these guys so you've
done the boxing thing you know the with
the boxing yes which i made no money off
of as well i know and i followed that
and i bought one oh yeah that was fun i
don't think you understand like i'm a
super fan i appreciate it and so i would
what i would do is the you you went to
the new house wearing
boxers right now
yeah i am i would go to the um
hawaii school of journalism i mean i i
think that that can you guys be my agent
i mean these are all great ideas i love
this stuff
i mean i just think that you could make
like
i i would imagine you could profit a
million dollars a year selling a 500 000
whole body school of like you've never
heard of me you've never heard of me
before with this podcast
i i did a course on writing how to be a
better writer and again i'm nobody and i
did i think what did i do 250k last
month in this course um and so you know
you sort of average that out across the
year i mean these are like kind of like
million dollar product lines i create
the course once and then i just run i
just say hey the new batch is open next
month and then it runs again and people
get great value at the end of the thing
i say hey you know you paid whatever 900
how much value do you think you got out
of this for you and your business your
career right and they're like you know
on average it's 10k basically is what
they say so they get 10x return on their
money uh from self-assessed on what they
believe they got out of the course so
you know i could send a film crew to you
right now and we could film a course on
how you know how to break into
journalism how to make it as a as a
journalist and then screw syracuse uh
the people who really want this all you
need is you know basically a thousand
people who really want this who pay you
a thousand dollars for this that's a
million dollars a year of basically pure
profit because the video production
costs are very very small for this
wow this is great stuff that
who would have thought i'd come on here
and get all these ideas i feel like my
head is spinning right now thank you can
you can you help us now
please
talk to me about audience building i
mean like i you seem like a guy who like
you don't have you don't do like a
significant amount of like growth
tactics you just you're just i think
you're talented and i think you're you
have tenacity so you've been doing it
for forever um but what have have for us
and anyone listening who wants to break
into to do what you've done what uh what
advice do you have on on audience
building and and
and getting i mean i know you don't
you're not you're not a like a
view at all but you know it's
still you want people to like your stuff
and you want a lot of people to like it
what do you have for that so my mindset
um was always okay the first thing was
you know look at the landscape look
who's out there doing things um it's
okay to derive some kind of inspiration
from this person or that person but at
the end of the day like you need to
develop a unique voice and give people a
reason to tune in to you right
don't be a copycat don't just try to do
something because someone else is doing
it and so that was my big thing and
that's why the interview lane i was like
oh no one is doing this in mma i should
you know develop
my own voice in this lane and be the guy
be the leader here and so that's the
first thing the the second thing is like
it's it's exhausting you know you have
to work your ass off to build the
audience to put the content out to make
it as good as possible um be consistent
you know pick a day if if you're doing a
podcast or something like pick a day
monday is your day
don't miss a monday you know like people
who do oh one here two here take a break
here it's very hard you have to be
consistent you have to be reliable you
have to be relentless you have to be
professional so my thing was you know
reaching out to the fighters and the
fighters um who i reached out to i was
very you know respectful towards i was
very professional towards i didn't keep
them for very long i would keep them for
like 20 minutes in hopes of
getting them to come back the next time
right because it's not just about this
time it's about the next time and the
next time and it's the next time and so
i don't want them in the back of their
mind to say like oh this guy kept me for
an hour what a pain in the ass i'm not
gonna you know do this again um and then
afterwards very thankful very respectful
very professional uh and then over time
you know it was like you know developing
these relationships um
checking in with fighters checking it
it's not in my world it's fighters but
it can be with anyone else if you're an
interviewer and you're interviewing tech
people and things like that like one big
thing is you know i don't just talk to
fighters um when i need something from
them i don't just reach out to michael
bisping when i want him on my show we
talk about things all the time i mean in
some respects some of these guys have
become friends of mine um and they don't
feel like they're being used it's
important to be a human being towards
your you know your your guests your
sources your things like that and so
then when it is time to ask for
something they are more than happy to
help you out because you've asked about
their dog who passed away or their wife
who had surgery or their son who won a
big thing in football or whatever and so
these are all kind of things that you
develop not with the you know it's to me
it's always very genuine i'm not doing
that i'm not checking in on the dog
because i hope that in three weeks it's
gonna pay off and he has you know you
know he he's willing to come on my show
it's just being a human being about all
this and working hard working your ass
off trying to be different putting the
content out
social media is a massive thing now
obviously you can't do a show without
having a social media presence and i
don't care if you have one follower or a
million followers you got to put the
clips out because it's so funny to me i
hear from people all the time like oh
that thing that uh rose said on your
show was awesome and then in back my
mind i'm like oh that's the one clip
that we chose from the interview did you
watch the interview or did you just
watch the clip on my instagram and
oftentimes it's just the instagram clip
and that's okay it's just about being
out there getting the stuff out there
making it shareable um and then
hopefully it attracts more people to
check you out and check you out but like
if this doesn't happen you know i
started this this particular part of my
life in 2007. i graduated in 2004 it
took me 14 years just to get to espn and
so a lot of people are impatient and
they want to
see the results right away it's just not
going to be that way
how many people first of all i want to
know how often are you working because
ufc fights end on one at 1am midnight in
new york and you do a post
you do a recap show often but how often
are you working and also how many people
does it take to run a content your
content operation
so i feel honestly i feel like i work
every day uh i don't know if that's good
or bad but it's it's for the most part
with pleasure like i i don't ever feel
like oh man i need a break i need a
vacation this and that now uh part of
going back to the therapist
i was terrified of leaving espn and then
kind of disappearing however i then came
to the conclusion hey you know what
distance makes the heart grow fonder for
me and for them and so june 15th was my
last day at espn and i essentially
disappeared until august 15th i was
still on social media i was still doing
stuff here and there but i took a
two-month break and it was freaking
awesome because i went home to canada to
see my parents for the first time in two
years because of the pandemic i just i
really needed that break um and i think
that that's important if you're doing
something you know for
uh you know for a very long time i think
it's important to give yourself you know
that type of uh break as well but um for
for the most part now i i feel like i'm
working every day especially with all
these different people and all these
different projects
and there's travel and stuff like that
uh there is no real break and i'm okay
with that um you just kind of find your
moments i can be a lot better i wish i
could put the phone away a lot sooner at
night i wish i didn't wake up and check
my phone right away i wish i was a
little more present um at times i'm
working on that but i got to tell you
guys like
i feel like i'm working every day but
i'm also in this state where i've never
been happier and uh
the the work has been so fulfilling
and it puts me in such a good mood to
create this stuff and to be there for
people like there is no greater
compliment that i can get when someone
writes me and said i had a horrible day
and then i checked out your show and it
made me forget about my day or during
the pandemic i was so down and you and
dc used to make me laugh and uh you know
i just got a message from someone who's
in australia and it's been horrible
there with the lockdowns and you you
know i'm so happy your show is four
hours again because you give me eight
hours a week of stuff to think about
outside of the lockdown i can think
about mma and i have access to these
fighters like there is no greater joy
than i get than that um and so i don't
mind it but also you know i haven't been
to a ufc fight
in a year and a half march of 2020 was
my last ufc fight and partly because of
the pandemic now partly because of my
job and you ask me right now
big time ufc fight um conor mcgregor's
return fight las vegas t-mobile sold out
crowd on a saturday night in july the
buzz the celebrities the atmosphere
nothing better right or
you ask me
do you want to go to your son soccer
game with 10 other parents there at the
park nearby i am choosing that soccer
game
without a a shadow shadow of a doubt in
my mind like i get so much enjoyment at
being at those games being a parent
being with my kids but then also doing
the work that fulfills me and makes me
happy there was a time where i thought i
had to be at every event leave my family
travel every weekend because i needed to
be omnipresent because woody allen once
said 80 of success is just showing up
and that served me early in my life and
career it doesn't serve me anymore and
so now that i'm able to pick and choose
what i want to do and work with people
who i want to work with and do the kind
of content that i want to do but also
be there for my family and my kids at
this stage of their lives gives me a lot
of joy and so i never thought i would
get to this point where wow i don't have
to go to the events and i could still do
great stuff and still be happy and still
be followed and still produce amazing
and still be there for my kids
in a weird world i'm so thankful to the
man above because i feel like it all
kind of like fell into place at this
point in my life
someone and send that clip to connor
ariel chooses
soccer game oh it's a six-year-old
soccer game
over conor mcgregor's return it's the
truth and it hasn't i just used conor
cause that's the biggest name possible
obviously
uh you know he's been very good to me
and it's been an absolute honor and i
would love to go to events you know of
course like one a week or sorry one a
year two a year three a year four like i
got to go to the jake paul thing that
was a great great experience um i was
just using the the most you know crazy
example possible the biggest name
possible the point is uh
i used to have fomo i used to feel sad
and depressed when i wasn't at the
events because uh i felt like i was
missing out i was becoming irrelevant
and uh i don't feel that way anymore i
feel very confident in what i'm doing
and before we wrap up the the content
team what's your team and process
looking at oh right yes um so right now
you know it kind of
so the dream obviously is to like you
know i think i don't know if you guys
are fans of pat mcafee but i think that
he is doing
media in sports at least better than
anyone right now um he's just doing an
incredible job and he has his group of
like i think eight or so guys doing work
for him and his social media is
brilliant because they're often tweeting
out things and he's not even a part of
it it's just like this well oil machine
and then he's going to do smackdown he
has his private plane i mean what a life
this guy lives now i am nowhere near
that at the moment uh i also didn't play
in the nfl
but
uh right now i have i would say
three people
who work
with me uh one person's social media one
person's video one person's audio
um and that's just me
you know my llc type of thing and then i
have people who are working on other
projects you know the vox stuff they
have people who work with me there
ringer people etc but yeah i would love
to to grow that out but i think the
three most important people to have
right now it doesn't have to be i mean
like i all those interviews that you saw
from me over the years i only had one
cameraman i didn't and and i didn't have
an audio person i didn't have anything
uh i don't think you need a gigantic
team of people to do stuff but yes it
would be nice over time to have you know
maybe two social media people and have
this person who's thinking of this and
someone who's you know managing like
i was laughing because you know you said
you had ben who did the scheduling and i
was like man i wish i had a ben i wish i
had someone doing my scheduling i wish i
would i was uh in that position or i
could even delegate some of that stuff
that's part you know my problem as well
i i don't do well at delegating um but
it will come it will grow and then
eventually it'll be fun to have a store
a merch store to do the stuff that
you're talking about and uh maybe make
money off of it and not feel bad about
it i mean there's a lot more i feel like
i'm just i'm 39
uh i've never been happier about you
know like my age my life um
and i remember when i i was a young kid
and we went to to boston and my mom
turned 40 and i remember she locked
herself in the bathroom and she was
crying because she was so sad that she
turned 40. and i joke about this with
her now as i'm about to turn 40. thank
god she's still alive and well and i'm
like i'm so happy to be 40. i feel i'm
way happier at 39 40 than i was at
1920 um and i just can't wait to see how
this all plays out last thing i wanted
to ask you real quick you mentioned jake
paul
and you talked about audience building
and all the good stuff uh consistency
quality hard work but there's also
controversy jake paul is the master of
controversy conor mcgregor is a master
of controversy and you have leaned into
the controversy i don't know if you've
leaned in i don't know if it's a work i
don't know if you if you if no actually
back no way but the con you know you are
the the number one mma guy and you're
banned for life from ufc
from ufc events by because the president
of the ufc has a feud with you and
brendan chubb now has a little bit of
feud with you and uh it's highly
entertaining i click every single one of
them because you know same everybody
loves drama everybody loves the fight uh
you know we all turn our heads uh and
look whenever there's there's a brawl
that breaks out i'm i'm i'm at your clip
his it's called ask the nose i believe
on the nose on the nose sorry and it's
been all about lately his fight with
other other folks it's great so tell me
about that leaning into that is that
intentional is that good for business uh
are you having fun with it you're
actually angry what's going on
okay well i'll just say i am not banned
for life i was banned for 48 hours but
that was back in 2016. over time there's
been some revisionist history where
people think i'm still banned i'm not
banned i've been to a bunch of events
since then um
but uh yes of course there was that feud
there that happened and all this stuff
and and that's all well and good and now
as i've come
you know into this new era and uh this
persona helwani thug knows el nadiz
whatever you want to call me
i've just enjoyed being able to
respond to people and i think part of
this comes from the fact that when i was
at espn they kept telling me take the
high road take the high road like a lot
of people were taking shots at me and i
had to take the high road take the high
road muzzle muzzle muzzle muzzle censor
yourself and then all of a sudden i
become
free
and uh i think as a byproduct of being
told to take the high road for the last
three years i just kind of snapped and
exploded and uh i think people have
enjoyed
see look i'm not this wimp that people
think i am uh i don't have big muscles
i'm not a fighter i'm not this but i'm a
crazy fiery middle eastern kid who grew
up uh getting into fights all the time
while i was playing sports arguing like
i'm not the
you know i have glasses i look nerdy
whatever i'm and at times i've actually
leaned into that because that's a good
gimmick in this world of you know big
strong fighters alpha males i'm the beta
but i'm really not that guy and the idea
of letting people
talk smack about me walk all over me
disparage my name lie about me it's just
not gonna happen anymore and so i don't
care and it was funny like brendan was
saying like i wouldn't say this to his
face like did you guys forget that i
stood in front of rampage jackson when
he wanted to like bite my head off did
you guys forget that nick diaz wanted to
beat me up did you guys forget that you
know mayhem miller trashed my studio and
i just sat there like
i would say anything to anyone's face
i'm not the guy who sits in front of a
keyboard or a camera and says stuff that
wouldn't you know that i wouldn't have
the courage to say in front of anyone
says and i don't think i'm disrespectful
i just you know am not that guy and so
uh i think he said a bunch of lies about
me and then i just kind of said
something and people liked it and then
he kept doubling down and so i didn't go
into all this saying like oh i'm gonna
come out and start wars with people and
start all this beef it's just like now i
don't have someone telling me to take
the high road and i'm a little older and
i'm a little more confident and i'm a
little wiser and uh people are enjoying
you know i i yeah i'll be honest like
i've realized over time you know people
want to know more about me they want to
see
me talk about myself it doesn't always
have to be about the guests and all that
stuff and that takes some time um you
know to get used to because it's it's
it's taught you know you're you're
you're taught very early on in your
career like it's not about you you're
not the story but um yeah now i'm just
having fun with it and yeah i'm a pro
wrestling fan and i i like the the drama
and all that stuff you could say what
you will about all of it but
at the end of the day none of it is fake
none of it is a work i'm not looking for
any of this i'm not trying to get paid
off of any of this i'm not trying to do
it for the views and all that i'm just
tired of people talking about me
and me having to eat it and so those
days are over and i don't care who you
are i'm going to clap back as they say
and uh i think i'm pretty damn good at
the promos and i may not be able to
fight you and have no interest in
fighting you but i think i could go
toe-to-toe with you in a uh in a verbal
war and so yeah
and it feels good to stick up for
yourself and this is why i was nervous
to talk to you is because i i i fully
believe that i i i
first you uh
you're sharp and you're not afraid so
we're at the top of the hour um yeah i
want to be respectful dude this has been
badass i hope hopefully you don't talk
too much about yourself like as a guest
and i hope you've enjoyed this because i
think i have enjoyed it i hope you guys
have enjoyed it i hope you felt like
this was worth your your while i
appreciate all the questions about
building the business and betting on
yourself and um
i'm learning a lot about that as well
now you know with all this llc stuff
that makes my head heard talking to my
accountant but i would urge anyone out
there who is passionate about what they
do and who believes in what they do i
don't have a lot of confidence like if
you and i i bet you sam you and i go get
a coffee right now
nearby
you are a much more confident person
than i am you will walk up there and
have your chest out and you and it's
probably because you just sold your
company for a few million and you're
loving life and and life could be better
i'm not i'm actually a very shy person a
quiet person i keep to myself i had
horrible social anxiety however when it
comes to this stuff i believe in myself
and i believe that no one can do it
better than me and that sounds cocky but
it took me a long time to actually be
able to say that
and so i'm really enjoying getting to do
this stuff on my own and getting to do
this stuff the way i want to do it
without anyone telling me how to do it
and i appreciate your interest in in my
story and i appreciate you guys
it's been a therapy session for all of
us maybe a little bit
well thursdays is my therapy day so uh i
i you know i was gonna have actually my
session i canceled it for you guys so i
i'm doubling down here because we were
supposed to i don't know if you guys
know this we were supposed to do this
last month and you stood me up and i'm
just joking i'm not gonna go back there
i hold on to things forever that's part
of my home as well yeah i know i know
i've listened to you long enough i know
this but i love it i do you gotta charge
more don't feel guilty about that that's
what as your therapist today that's that
would be my feedback because if you are
the best you you deserve the best thank
you i appreciate that in fact i don't
know when this is coming out but i'll
just say part of you know me trying to
tinker with things i'm doing a thing for
founding members of my sub stack um this
evening i'll do it three more times over
the course of the year where it's just
the founding members the people who paid
180 to sign up so the sub stack is five
dollars a month 50 a year or there's the
founding member
deal which is 180. um i picked 180
because the number 18 is a special
number for jewish people um and i'm
doing a super secret vvip one night only
no holds barred zoom chat with uh the
people who signed up where they can ask
me whatever they want for an hour i'm
gonna be there are you gonna be there
yes
well i appreciate you signing up
yes but don't record this and take notes
and post it to your millions of
followers because it's supposed to be
vvvp i'm going to spill all the tea
release all the dirt on all the bad
people out there but it's just for us
our little group and there's not i don't
honestly i'm kind of nervous that no
one's going to show up so the f it might
just be me and you sam just for the
record i would love that
come true
as sam calls it
yeah
well thanks man this is badass hopefully
uh you've enjoyed it uh
this is awesome you got to come back
again i would i would be happy to just
don't you know
stand me up next time
yeah let go bro
thanks guys
[Music]